Nega Markel and Prince Harry are taking
legal action against British tabloids on
Tuesday the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
announced that they are suing associated
newspapers the owners of the Daily Mail
Mail Online Metro and more this after
The Mail on Sunday published a private
handwritten letter that Meghan wrote to
her estranged father Thomas Markel in a
statement Harry revealed that this has
been many months in the making
adding quote unfortunately my wife has
become one of the latest victims of a
British tabloid press that we just
campaigns against individuals with no
thought to the consequences a ruthless
campaign that is escalated over the past
year throughout her pregnancy and while
raising our newborn son the 35 year old
new dad goes on to explain that he and
Megan have put on a brave face but he
can't even begin to describe how painful
it has been Harry also calls out the
publications in question for the double
standards that have vilified Megan
almost daily for the past nine months
and says he has been a silent witness to
a private suffering for too long
according to multiple reports the Sussex
is are using private funds for the case
meanwhile ET has reached out to the
Daily Mail and dmg T formerly known as
associated newspapers for more
information we feel a tremendous
responsibility to play our part in
effecting societal change for the better
the issue hits close to home for Harry
his late mother Princess Diana was
hounded by the British press throughout
her life and was fleeing from the
paparazzi when she died in a car crash
in Paris
back in August 1997 the Duke ended his
statement explaining that his deepest
fear is history repeating itself